because if we really did all that we
think we did we would have the outcomes
we'd have all these smart women and then
I started looking at female CEOs and it
was like every time a chick would like
take over they would just like run it
into the ground I don't say this like
guys you know
I I make
a lot of money for my age you know I'm
I'm really successful for for a woman
but no even for a guy but really I think
what makes me successful is trusting men
to make decisions to be honest because
you know
um I had to get a lot of advice from men
and every time I have to make a business
decision I go to my dad and
I just think like if women like I I just
I literally guys I could not stop
thinking about this last night